great to be here thanks for being on the
show well thank you i gotta say watching
the and i see these blade movies wesley
snipes just comes across as
you know the uh
he's not a bowl full of laughs in these
movies and he's in the character he's a
hard well he's in character the whole
time he doesn't activate wesley stays in
character from the day you start he's
he's absolutely blade he's a hard ass
and and and you know i i don't i don't
think he liked me very much
oh really well you're a jokey or a very
funny guy but you like to cut up a
little fun sure well you're doing that
around wesley trying to loosen him up a
bit i tried yes
yeah i mean you know he's he's the guy
was born to play this role he's a
legendary character and uh he takes it
very seriously so i mean it's not like
we we walked on the stage each day with
our you know pinkies interlocked
yeah you don't ask him like what he
thought of last week's episode of
touched by an angel right not like a
friendly cuddly guy like that right
right yeah so what was your did you ever
make a like an attempt to say like small
talk with with with wesley snipes on the
set once in a while but you know that's
like a you know you don't you also don't
want to you want to respect his process
and you don't want to take him out of
the character but i did ask him how his
weekend was once and uh and he said
something very sweet he said save your
breath you'll live longer
and i don't look at that as a snub i
just think that's tough love yeah yeah i
wonder what kind of hallmark cards he
sends to people i don't know you will
die soon merry christmas uh end
miserably yeah yeah you uh i saw this
today
just insanity this is the cover of men's
health i never look at this magazine i'm
not a healthy person but look at the
shape look at the shape this guy got
onto got into ladies and gentlemen to
prepare for this role is this
you know what that's guy is wooing is
this is this is this your head pasted
onto somebody else's body because what
people don't know is that when i exhale
actually turn into tom arnold right
right in that picture what is it i mean
i i
i just i don't want to freak anybody out
my body looks nothing like that i don't
even think i don't think i'm the same
species as this to do this movie they
you know this was part of the
requirement you know seven months of uh
eating you know whole chickens and
horses and children all the time and
lifting as much
yeah it's very controversial
okay but this is the difference between
us i could quit this show eat the same
thing you ate have the same regimen lift
all those weights i would never
get a stomach that looked like that
because i am irish
i'm irish yeah i am the kind of irish
where we have no definition it is not
possible
it is not i like mine this is the belly
of like a bass right here just a smooth
smooth pale slick gray white
oily
uh
scaly fish belly but you're married you
don't need anything you don't need it
anymore you know what if you put a nice
like you could with computer-generated
imagery you can do anything you could
get you in a nice blue unitard that
could just
no one would have bought it no one wants
to see that we've made calls
i've looked into it the other thing i've
heard is that some actors you can
actually have a makeup artist draw the
pecs on your stomach they can actually
draw them and i was thinking of having a
makeup artist a really good hollywood
one do the pecs just draw it draw on and
then have a tattoo artist go over it in
ink so it's permanent and then i will
walk around with a six-pack all the time
an enormous amount of effort yeah
and then for a man who wears a suit
every day you know it's mistake it's
just for me at night when i'm you know
getting ready to take a shower like
check me out yeah you want to pose down
um sorry i was late for work there was a
mirror on the way
you'll forgive me
do you um you you handle a lot of guns
in this film a lot of like a lot of guns
is that fun to do i don't get to do that
in my job it's terrifying you know what
a lot of people don't know because
they're real guns and they really they
shoot the blanks of course but you know
it's like you you you as soon as you put
one in my hand i just start sweating
like just freaking out pouring out of
every pore it's awful and uh and you
know you learn all this terminology that
is just absolutely useless you know you
have the the quarter load caps which is
one of the bullets that that make a
slight bang you have the half loads and
you have the full loads and they always
in these movies they want the big muzzle
flash so they use these full loads and
when you go home at the end of the day
and your you know your girlfriend's like
how was your day honey and it just
doesn't sound right you're like oh i
shot a full load at some guy
[Applause]
what a wonderful holiday anecdote thank
you
merry christmas
people are here to see the christmas
tree and we'll see coming too
what happened
next flight to you shouldn't come here
and you know it all right
you